foreign
[Music]
what were the seven dragons seen in the
seventh episode of House of the Dragon
we'll hear on Dragon watch in mind Q we
shall tell you which one is which
including the rider that belongs to the
dragon as well so let's get to it
the first one is Cyrax this dragon is
one that is bonded to the air of the
Iron Throne princess renera Targaryen he
is seen flying above the funeral in
driftmark he seems to have only grown
slightly over the 10 years plus that has
passed since the last episode we saw of
him he is bright golden color with
golden wings a long tail with fins and a
Sleek body design his head has two large
horns and two smaller ones on the side
the next one is melees she is also seen
in the same episode and on the same
scene alongside Cyrax and three others
melees the Red Queen is seen flying over
in the distance being red in color and
having a Sleek yet a more robust body
design melees is a dawn with a crown
full of horns starting from the back of
the skull this dragon is the Mount of
Princess rhaenys Targaryen
then we see caraxis immediately after
melees flying at a nearer distance and
we do know that this is the dragon man
of Prince Daemon Targaryen karaxi is
also known as a blood worm is a red
dragon that is deformed and has a very
serpent-like body design with hind legs
that possess an extra pair of gliding
Wings he also has a fork tail and seems
to look like Smaug from a distance
next is C smoke in the same scene we see
sea smoke the dragon mount of Lena
valerion at first we thought it was
dream fire from the last episode but we
can clearly see that he only seemed
darker because of the Shadows he is a
pale and ashy colored dragon with
pinkish winged membranes he looks very
similar to the dragons of Daenerys from
Game of Thrones
then at last we see Sunfire right in
front of seismo to his left we get the
first glimpse of The Magnificent Golden
Dragon that is on fire this dragon is
the Mount of Prince aegon II and he
looks very similar to Cyrax almost too
similar almost indistinguishable at
first but we can make out that he has
pinkish Wing membranes just like seismo
and also two very long pair of horns on
his head longer than those of Cyrax he
is also quite small in size those are
the differences between Cyrax and
Sunfire
then vegar in the middle of the episode
we get to see the largest of them all
Vega are still feeling down upon the
loss of a dragon rider maybe because she
burned her alive vegar is seen bonding
with a young prince Eamon Targaryen she
was reluctant at first but then
eventually let Amon claim her she is a
beast and with this episode we can now
clearly estimate her size but that'll be
in another video Vega has a dinosaur
appearance with a rubbery leathery skin
and a pair of wings that are absolutely
massive even with her size she can still
fly like a fighter jet in disguise
and lastly dream fire in the last scenes
of this episode during King viserys's
departure from driftmark we can see Vega
organic flight with aemon on top of him
and immediately in the background we see
a pair of dragons with one being Sunfire
and the other being dream fire we know
this for a fact because the only dragons
aside from Sunfire and Vega that are in
the possession of the greens which were
a faction of Queen Alison was Princess
Helena's Mount dream fire and his dragon
is a pale bluish Dragon similar to Sea
smoke in body design so I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit the
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam